[Music]
aaron is with us in orlando hi erin how
are you
i'm doing great dave how are you doing
today better than we deserve what's up
i wanted to call dave because my wife
and i would like to ask a question about
upgrading our housing situation we're
currently on baby step six right now and
we're we've maxed out our 401k roth
contributions as well as an additional 6
000 per roth ira
and during the time of pandemic when
we've seen so many people struggling
we've been so um fortunate where our
careers have really really blossomed
and a big dream of my wife has always
been to move to a certain area in
orlando as well as myself
and upgrade our housing and right now we
have the ability to save on average
about an additional 50 to 75 000 a year
that we'd like to put towards making
this purchase
we want to be patient about this
purchase because there's not a lot of
houses that come up for sale in this
area regularly when they do they go very
very quickly and we're just not in that
position quite yet so my question for
you is
would you take this additional 50 to 75
000 that we're making additionally on an
annual basis and just pay down our
current mortgage
or would you take that and put that
maybe in a gross mutual stock
or mutual funds uh arena to let it grow
and then use that towards
paying towards the down payment of the
house when we find the right deal at the
right time
oh you're going to sell your house
aren't you
absolutely
sure you're going to get your money out
of it anyway
correct we we currently owe about 230
000 on our home right now and it's worth
over 400 so we have a good let's just
say that
let's just say your careers continue to
blossom and you paid it off yes sir
and then you found the house in the
dream neighborhood you just put that one
on the market and sell it and use that
for the down payment right
correct my wife um she she's the one
that's getting more analytical about it
she's wondering if we're better off
using it and seeing maybe that eight
percent growth on it as opposed to just
we're paying right now two point six two
five percent on our mortgage rate and
she thought maybe be better off you know
investing it there and seeing growth
there rather than paying down the
mortgage itself yeah
that's when you didn't do math um
because here's the problem okay
the way you get into that new
neighborhood
has got
95 percent to do with you saving fifty
to a hundred thousand dollars a year
it has one percent to do with what the
rate of return on your savings is
the math that gets you into that
neighborhood is not is not rate of
return
it's your savings rate
based on your income
so you know if you want to use that
argument that she's using we would never
pay off the mortgage
correct yes my contention is i'd like to
pay off the mortgage because i would
like to be able to do my debt free
screen no matter what well yeah and and
in either way either way you get to your
goal
uh but the the idea that that somehow
making a little bit more on your money
is going to get you to the goal faster
no you're adding risk to the equation
and i wouldn't do that i would continue
to work your plan
um and the other thing i think i heard
is that you're putting more than 15 of
your income into retirement
correct sir
yeah because i would hold up at baby
step four at fifteen percent going into
retirement and i would throw everything
else at the mortgage that's the baby
steps
the the additional amount is more
towards uh looking towards the kids for
their education for college
i'm said 15 towards retirement
oh yeah you said you maxed out
everything are your income so high that
maxing out everything
uh is 15 of your income
um
i believe the maximum a lot we're
allowed to uh deposit is it 18 000 750
or something like that this year this
year
yeah
yeah so we've matched that out
completely and then we started is that
more than 15 percent of your income
yes it is sir okay that's not one
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry it is it is more i'm
sorry i i i yeah and so you're putting
in 22 to 25 of your income instead of
15 of your income i would back that down
throw everything at your house let's get
your house paid for pile up cash once
the house is paid for beyond that um but
um
yeah so so
yeah you guys uh i mean that's what we
teach
again you can do your plan if you're
under your plan but 15
is the most of your household income
take your household income times 0.15 is
the most i'd be putting into those 401ks
and roth iras anything beyond that kids
college anything beyond that we're
paying down the house going to get it
paid for and then you'll be ready
christy to move into that other house
well the other thing that uh that i love
that you pointed out dave is it's not
just about the money as it is we're
talking about like where you put the
money the risk and so aaron you want to
get in this special neighborhood that's
hard to get into you're going to be in a
really good position if you have hardly
any mortgage or a paid off house and
then some saved up cash when you make an
offer on a home in any kind of market
versus worrying about what the mutual
funds are doing or whatever you're just
going to have so much more control to
make a good offer and have a good
position for that house you want and
that's what we're trying to help you do
we're trying to help you get in a good
position
financially but also from a control
standpoint in options yeah so you guys
are um
again you can work your plan your wife's
plan if you want to
that's allowed you know there's nothing
against the law but we are firmly
convinced after 30 years of doing this
that if you will follow those baby steps
exactly you're going to find yourself in
wealth faster than any other methodology
and we've actually got millions and
millions of people that have done it
that are the data points that indicate
that it's not it's not a
you know college professor with a theory
um been doing this a long time with tens
of millions of people we were just we're
just saying as we walked out in the
break to congratulate those people
debt-free on their house we're seeing a
lot more people paying off their homes
and it's a result of those
tens you know it's the number of years
yeah the 30 years of doing this you know
when i hadn't been on the air eight
years i couldn't have somebody come in
here and go eight years ago i started
listening to you and but now that i've
been on the air 30 years there's a whole
bunch of them that are out there that um
that you know they're further along and
we're also seeing the you know the other
piece of it which is the financial piece
babies my parents listened to you when i
was a kid oh shut up you know but um
yeah just make make dave feel old
statement but
um but you don't have to make me feel
old i'm well aware of my age but the uh
but you know
the thing is this stuff works it's
always worked it still works you know
ramsay's people are out of touch no
we're not we're in touch with the truth
uh we know exactly how wealth is built
in today's world the fastest possible
way
and there's a lot of stuff we don't
think about around here but that's not
one of them we
we are the expert on that in in the
whole freaking nation so and it's you
know it's not um
my age does not disqualify that as a
matter of fact it qualifies it so well
you don't understand modern yes i do you
goob
i understand modern everything i can
even work my own phone go figure
you know so but this idea that somehow
that the principles of wealth building
have somehow
shifted dramatically in the past 10
years and ramsay's a boomer and doesn't
get it it's just asinine yeah just
ridiculous so the principles are all
have always been the same they will
always be the same
and now the vehicles you use might shift
some of those things might change but
you know you don't you can't use that to
be uh to make an excuse to get in to get
rich quick garbage well you make you
always make a good point too don't take
financial advice from broke people and
half the time the people that are
telling you
you should be doing this you have to
build a credit score you have to take
out debt you have to have a mortgage you
should put your money in this whatever
they're people that are deeply in debt
there are people that are not winning
financially these are not the kind of
people you want to listen to if the
financial blogger you're reading lives
in his mother's basement there's a
problem here
you know i mean we need a track record
we need proof there's just a there's a
little bit of something going on here i
got socks older than him
so um but that that's the trick you just
got to think this through and um
you know
there isn't a thing called experience
and proof
texting in that experience